[Music]
Merkin games have become something of a
staple in gaming news lately from the
malfunctioning multiplayer in halo the
Master Chief collection to Assassin's
Creed unity faceless French protagonist
games that launched with a bevy of bugs
and glitches are nothing new but there's
certainly some infamous standout
examples although SimCity gave us a
brand new hatred for always online and
basically every Bethesda RPG delivered
on obscure bugs here are 5 of my picks
for hugely broken games
sonic boom rise of lyric may have been
dubbed sonic boom by our review but it
still doesn't hold a candle to the
terribleness of Sonic the Hedgehog from
2006 considered to be one of the worst
games ever 2006 is sonic on ps3 and 360
had crappy controls a disasterous camera
and commited what is one of the worst
sins in game design it was unfinished
with promised features that never made
an appearance that's even after Sonic
Team took extra time to work on it the
game was announced in 2005 by Yuji naka
lead programmer on the very first Sonic
game on the Sega Master System and who
was heading up Sonic Team at the time it
was probably a bad sign when he resigned
just after the game was announced Sonic
oh 6 also features the super yucky kiss
between Sonic and the human princess
Elise that were all still trying to
bleach from our memories this next one
is probably the only part of the
Superman franchise that makes you think
twice about whether or not you actually
want to be a superhero in Superman 64 it
sucks
potentially the only game ever to make
simulated flying not fun Superman 64 was
a Nintendo 64 game that focused on
flying through featureless grey skies
peppered with rings and clipping into
the environment the graphics were also
widely panned
even for 1999 standards and the game
really only succeeded in getting a
generation of kids to almost unanimously
prefer Batman over Superman no contest
hopping back into the 21st century I'd
be remiss not to mention the biggest
triple a broken game off the last
several years
SimCity was bad battlefield 4 was worse
EA faced multiple lawsuits because so
many people bought and attempted to play
the fairly broken shooter instead of
battling in fields what they faced with
significant technical issues including
stability problems glitches which
trapped the player in certain screens
let them trade kills to artificially pad
stats alongside many other issues as
well as various crashes across platforms
the game was being patched and updated
constantly all the way up until last
month when developer dice finally
acknowledged that they really screwed up
and betrayed the trust of their fans
you've probably heard of this one since
its spawned its very own meme and scored
a zero out of ten from one publication
yep a zero if you haven't guessed it
already it's big rigs over the road
racing the game that giant bombs alex
navaro called as bad as your mind will
allow you to comprehend bursts of the
famous your winner meme unfortunately
the game's issues didn't start and end
with poor grammar this number one
all-time worst game on gamerankings is
horrendously broken completely
unfinished in every conceivable way and
well it made this happen
[Music]
[Music]
and then there's air control this one
actually came out this year and almost
broke senior review at Kevin vanore who
had the misfortune of playing it
certainly not as well-known as big rigs
but equally as frustrating air control
doesn't even have a mildly functioning
user interface it's full of stolen
graphics clunky character models and the
mouse look that is bound to the cursor
so whenever you want to click on
something the whole screen shifts the
screen is inexplicably peppered with
buttons that say look cursor and the
actual tasks of the game which include
picking up pillows and delivering coffee
on an airplane are exactly as mundane
and uninspired as the sound you might
think it's worth it to take out stilted
exploding terrorists or opt for a mode
where the plane is full of wildlife but
trust me you'll have way more fun
crashing your polygonal plane into the
in game see that's actually solid and
giving up on this one these five games
are totally terrible but let me know
which one you think is the most working
or if I missed out on one of your picks
I will see you next week
you